-You have made
quite an effort to be here,
because I saw you live
at 2:00 a.m.
on the White House lawn
last night.
That's in D.C.
That's not here.
-It's 3 1/2 hours away.
-3 1/2 hours away.
So, talk me through --
'Cause you were on
"The Today Show" this morning.
-Right.
-So, what was
your schedule, then,
after you wrapped at 2:00 a.m.?
-So, go home, pack a bag,
hop a flight,
first shuttle out of Washington
to come here, "Today Show,"
I did my show for MSNBC,
and I don't know if you heard,
the President held
a press conference today.
-Yeah, he did.
[ Light laughter ]
-And so, we did special reports
for that for NBC News,
2 1/2 hours.
This thing was long.
It was his longest
press conference ever.
And then, I was doing
a pre-interview
with one of your producers
for this show,
and Jeff Sessions resigned.
-Yeah.
-And then,
we hopped off the phone
and went back in it for that.
-There's so much
to unpack there.
Let's start with Sessions,
in that he did not mention it.
Donald Trump did not mention it
during a hour and a half
press conference.
-Well, he was asked...
-Yes.
-...about him very specifically.
-And yet chose --
But there's obviously something
he knew was happening.
What is your take on this?
-Yeah.
-What are you hearing
from your sources
as far as was this
a forced resignation?
-100%, the President
asked Jeff Sessions to resign.
Jeff Sessions handed him
that resignation letter,
which said,
"You asked me to resign.
Here is my resignation letter."
[ Laughter ]
This is not surprising.
This was expected.
This has been rumored,
if you guys follow the news,
rumored for months and months.
That doesn't mean it's not
still significant, right?
This is a really sort of
critical moment here.
Because if you look at the arc
of where Republicans were,
for example, back last year,
remember when Lindsey Graham,
the Senator, said,
"There will be holy hell to pay
if Donald Trump
fires Jeff Sessions."
Lindsey Graham
has certainly changed his tune
as Republicans
have come to accept, I think,
kind of reluctantly that
relationship is just broken.
It's broken beyond repair.
So, what I'm hearing,
what we're hearing
from our team at NBC News,
is that Jeff Sessions
may not be gone
from the political world.
He's considering possibly,
per people close to him,
running for his old Senate seat
back in Alabama.
-That Doug Jones seat.
Right.
-Going up against Doug Jones.
So he may end up
back in Washington,
perhaps working with or against
President Trump again.
-I don't think he'll ever work
against President Trump.
That is my takeaway.
I feel as though most
of the Republicans who've shown
any resistance to him ultimately
are never going to
truly resist anything
Donald Trump tries to do.
-The interesting thing
about Jeff Sessions is,
there's a lot of headlines --
Listen, this all matters
as it relates --
A lot of it matters
as it relates
to the Special Counsel
investigation, right?
Which Jeff Sessions
recused himself from.
That was, in the eyes of the
President, the original sin,
the thing he could never forgive
Jeff Sessions for.
But here's the thing --
if you look at the DOJ,
they've actually
implemented almost more
than any other agency,
Donald Trump's agenda.
-Yeah.
-Jeff Sessions has done exactly
what Donald Trump
has wanted him to do.
So there's this really
interesting, I think,
split or dichotomy
between the political sphere,
the political side of it,
and then the policy side.
-I want to ask about the fact
that Donald Trump --
You know,
the Russia investigation
is the reason
he fires Jeff Sessions.
Obviously, that's a little bit
more stressful for him now
that the Democrats have taken
back the House
and they have
this power of oversight.
Do you think --
Obviously, based on
the press conference today,
it struck me that was a man
who was a little stressed out.
Is it likely that
that's what stressing him out?
-Part of it, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Listen, for the first time,
he's now in Washington,
he's inside the White House,
and he is facing
a check on his power.
That has not happened
for him before.
So, I think he's in this mode
where he's looking around,
and that's what
we're hearing from folks is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
And he's seeing,
"Hey, now Democrats do control
the House of Representatives."
There will be
an onslaught of subpoenas,
and that's a hassle
for West Wing staffers.
You have to deal with that.
It's paperwork, it's time,
it's energy,
and it's also something
that Donald Trump knows
is going to be coming.
Now, what he did today
was issue, essentially,
a threat to the Democrats.
Like, "Hey, I'll work with you
on infrastructure,
I'll work with you on trade,
but not if you come at me
about my tax returns,"
for example.
Nancy Pelosi didn't seem so keen
on that when she spoke, so...
-Well the thing I would say
why he wouldn't be keen on it,
and this is just based
on everything
he's ever said or done,
I don't believe
that he's actually
gonna be honest on that deal.
Right?
Do actually see --
Do you think if Democrats
laid off tax returns
he would actually
make a deal on infrastructure?
-So, here's what I can say.
This is a president
and this is a person --
and I've covered Donald Trump
for his campaign, his candidacy,
the transition,
the presidency now.
He is somebody
who has issued threats
and not always
followed through with them,
and that's just
the facts of the case.
So there's not a lot
of past history to point to
that the President would
necessarily follow through
on the threat
that's he's making today.
-You've been
in a lot of press conferences.
Were you watching today
at that mayhem,
and was part of you
jealous that you weren't there?
Or were you more super-relieved
that you were safely far away?
-Oh, my God.
I was crawling out of my skin
making phone calls this morning
like, "I got to skip Seth.
I got to go back."
But I had to be in New York
anyway for my MSNBC show.
We have an awesome team
at NBC News,
and so they were out there
repping NBC.
I will say this, though.
Watching, and we were sort of
on set doing the analysis piece
for NBC News for our stations
throughout the day.
There were moments --
That was tense
and uncomfortable.
That's not a hot take.
That's, like,
a very lukewarm take.
-Yeah.
-A press conference
that is not normal
for the East Room, necessarily.
But the attacks on the media
and the way that he has
these sort of moments
and interactions,
that actually does well for him
among his supporters,
and that's
something to remember,
that that actually
plays for him.